confessor ten-second Ishi Asian retro
your mission should you choose to accept
it is to bypass bloom security doors and
get inside then find and erase your
personal CTOs profile whatever they have
on me it's all [ __ ] and I'm sick of
getting a little rascal
all the more reason for purge will be
watching try to keep up by the way we
put this plan us together to set the
mood hope you like it
you're wasting your time
he's not in gotcha
so that's him he's got a gun is that a
problem problems why you keep me around
right time him I'm curious too late he's
in already
give me a real Lance I'm just not that
into aliens or video games it's not just
any Amy come on anyone else having a
problem with their
so what's the deal it was raised in
Oakland but was born in this deal is
he's been hanging around the 10sec IRC
and he's got crap figured we'd give him
a test drive on the hardest difficulty
nobody's been able to delete their CTOs
profile before I want to see if he's
smart and stubborn or books
I need power
hey where do you going out fine
you're already going on
yeah okay fine
see Gio has tagged him as the prime
suspect in high-tech burglaries so he's
done time community service not enough
evidence just the word of CTOs has
predictive algorithms but once in the
system always in the system
your hands up
he's going in that Potter it's at least
120 degrees in there
give the man props it's going to Mile
he's in the system nobody's gotten that
far this is like the secret cow level
what the [ __ ]
why is my threats away
this is [ __ ]
or I could just
just gonna drop a little backdoor into
the system so I can get back inside
later Solly Blayne we've got unfinished
business he's heading out
[ __ ] you bloom in 2013 Chicago realized
the promise of smart cities with CTOs a
citywide operating system merging big
data with surveillance security and
transit programs with a few hundred
lines of code hackers were able to
hijack its central servers and [ __ ]
the entire grid many believe the attack
would be a killing blow for smart city
development they were wrong coordinated
from the heart of Silicon Valley CTOs
2.0 has been implemented across the
United States assuring in the Internet
of Things 6.4 billion connected devices
now serve as collection points mapping
and recording our daily routines making
a more secure and more invasive system
but who else is listening
Big Brother no longer works alone
thousands of little brothers monitor and
aggregate your every move building a
complete digital profile of you to be
bought sold for stolen in an instant
toys study your children reporting their
play habits back to marketers appliances
consoles and home security systems give
corporations a window into your private
life control of your vehicle and mobile
device can now be breached remotely by
anyone at any time you may think that
you are immune or underestimate the risk
but your digital shadow is already
compromised insurance companies use
algorithms to monitor your life habits
and limit or deny coverage health
providers determine if your cancer is
worth treating search results and news
fees are skewed to buy a smooth and
influence your vote engineering social
up
things on a massive scale you are now
less valuable than the data you produce
this is the new reality going dark is no
longer an option with threats to
personal freedom rising many are
stepping forward whistleblowers
activists and hackers have drawn their
battle lines putting the establishment
on watch but are they
threats themselves or have they become
freedoms last line of defense
so
am I in
welcome to dedsec
I'm satara this sweetheart
is Josh aka hot sauce yo your hot sauce
yep man I loved your frat house hat real
talk
Thanks this weirdos ranch the needs of
the many
and this Casanova is Horacio
what's up brother mmm it's the crew huh
took y'all long enough to come get me
[ __ ] you saw boom [ __ ] CTOs isn't
just regulating infrastructure the
amount of personal data that thing is
collecting is [ __ ] mind yeah it's big
brother and little brother all rolled up
into one huh sees everything you do
Intel's on there
Thank You Josh so what's the fix
sledgehammers and fire no sledgehammers
on fire all that data in one place means
they can reject your [ __ ] application
before you click on it
congratulations you have been pre
rejected for how credit card Oh your
house or your insurance that's not even
the worst case scenario all that data in
the hands of the government they'll
arrest you for [ __ ] before you even do
it yeah I've been there now [ __ ] know
why [ __ ] it [ __ ] it man what hackers
we all think we out dare as I say we
dead on the [ __ ] wall
hey show everyone what what blooms up to
man
show me show the world that their
personal data is being used to rob them
of their [ __ ] freedoms [ __ ]
I installed a backdoor so all I do is
walk right through
hold on what you installed it back doors
so we have to do is walk through bingo
hey man see you at the time oh yeah
together you get it now late for night
run isn't it hey where'd you put you've
read it from the cops
maybe I am one hey familiar have a good
party
for King this
[ __ ] you bloom I'm gonna go ahead with
damn good time